what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
conversations with a feminist i'm a
conservative and i'm a feminist
okay guys do not forget to subscribe to
the channel and bring that notification
bell the way you're going to be notified
of my daily videos um today we are
reacting to facts about slavery that
were never mentioned in schools before i
start tell them people where they can
find you um you can find me on my new
youtube channel it'll be linked it's
called life with raw but yeah it'll be
what are you gonna what type of content
this is to be announced but yeah it'll
be it'll be fun okay
so thomas sowell is one of my favorite
authors
and i just thought we should react to
this one you ready yep okay
we will not support you yeah i'm sorry i
won't buy your patreon sir
oh your favorite book
the instrumental use of the history of
slavery today also underlies the claim
that slavery grew out of racism
for most of its long history which
includes most of the history of the
human race
slavery was largely not the enslavement
of racially different people for the
simple reason that only in recent
centuries has either the technology or
the wealth existed to go to another
continent to get slaves and transfer
screaming
i don't think it's like most of the
history of the human race
what do you mean he said
like
like because the world didn't begin
in the [ __ ] 1800s or whatever oh no i
know
wait so what are you saying
i just
okay but then hamas across an ocean
people were enslaved
because they were vulnerable not because
of how they looked
the peoples of the balkans were enslaved
by fellow europeans as well as by the
peoples of the middle east for at least
six centuries before the first african
was brought to the western hemisphere
before the modern era by and large
europeans enslaved other europeans
asians enslaved other asians africans
enslaved other africans and the
indigenous peoples of the western
hemisphere enslaved other indigenous
peoples of the western hemisphere
slavery was not based on race much less
on theories about race
only relatively late in history did
enslavement across racial lines occur on
such a scale as to promote an ideology
of racism that outlasted the institution
of slavery itself
wherever a separate people were enslaved
they were disdained or despised whether
they were different by country religion
caste race or trial
so i actually didn't know that when i
first read this book yeah that's true
it's even in the bible that like it was
such a global institution like because
when i was growing up like they always
just said it was like white versus black
no like
yeah i mean this is slavery has always
been like
i guess in death since so i guess
technically he's right in the beginning
because
he's always been slavery like howl's
like always going to be an underdog
yeah five now in east africa the messiah
were feared slave raiders and other
african tribes either alone or in
conjunction with arabs enslaved their
more vulnerable neighbors
as late as 1891 it was reported that
manuema slavers had demoralized
surrounding tribes destroying crops and
famine reigned everywhere
even in the early 20th century
abyssinians were still raiding other
africans and carrying off slaves
it was 1922 before the british had
gained sufficient control in tanganyika
to stamp out slavery there
arabs were the leading slave raiders in
east africa ranging over an area larger
than all of europe the total number of
slaves exported from east africa during
the 19th century has been estimated to
be at least 2 million
the form in which the story of slavery
has reached most people today has been
along the lines of the best-selling book
and widely watched television
mini-series roots by alex haley
challenged on the historical accuracy of
roots haley said
i tried to give my people a myth to live
by
this instrumental use of history or
purported history is open to the same
objections as other instrumental
myth-making
despite the impression created by roots
during the era of the massive slave
trade from west africa a white man was
more likely to catch malaria in africa
than to catch slaves himself
the average life expectancy of a white
man in the interior of sub-saharan
africa at that time was less than one
year
by and large men from europe or the
western hemisphere came to the coasts of
africa bought their slaves and left as
soon as possible
even so the death rates among the white
crews of the ships carrying slaves to
the western hemisphere were as high as
the death rates among the slaves
themselves it was only much later after
quinine and other medical measures
enabled europeans to survive where there
were tropical diseases was it possible
for them to invade africa in force and
establish empires there
but by then the atlantic slave trade had
already been ended
during the era of that trade africa was
largely ruled by africans who
established the conditions under which
slave sales took place
the crew of a slave ship was in no
position to defy african rulers and
their armies by going out across the
land and capturing people willy-nilly
the stronger african peoples captured
and enslaved the weaker peoples the same
pattern found over the centuries in
europe asia the western hemisphere and
polynesia
in the asa land the angoni and yao
swaggered over and terrorized other
tribes in uganda the baganda made life
miserable for their neighbors and the
niyoro and hima of anko enslaved toro
women and children the tutsi dominated
the hutu in rwanda the messiah lorded
over the kukuyu and kamba and the latter
in turn held the indorobo in a kind of
serfdom
it was precisely the fact that europeans
except for the portuguese
okay
do you ever think about
how
like slavery's still going on today in
like certain parts of the world yeah i
mean it's different forms of slavery so
like there's like sex slaves
that's the most common slavery today is
sex slaves it's just interesting like i
feel like
there's no one in the us that's really
like doing anything about stuff like
that
i feel like there are people i can't
give you a name because i don't like
yeah but there are people that are like
trying to fight against um
sex slaves
i don't is that the right term it's just
not like a big
issue i guess like i don't think we talk
about it enough it is but also it's
basically how how it is is whenever
people say something about um like
trying to stop sex slave it's like
the way that is as if higher people are
for it so they're not going to stop
something that they're for say say um
jeffrey epstein
um
any anyone that
it could potentially come out with
evidence they're they're suddenly dead
yeah all right a heart attack like the
clock have you ever seen the clinton
body count
no it's like
people that basically
accused the clintons of doing [ __ ] and
just like wounded up dead
yeah but so it's it's along those lines
it's not that people don't care it's the
along the lines that people that are
speaking up against those things are
so what do you think about what he's
talking about in the video how it was
like a global institution i because i
seriously did not know this like
um just how widespread it was all over
the world
like i really thought it was just an
american thing for like the longest time
really yeah i really did because that
was the only one i heard about mm-hmm
but the the
you know the
um
the caribbean than in america that's
what they say they well i heard that
like the the middle east was the worst
like the arabs arabs arabs
but they um
they're gonna roast me for that but they
like most of the slaves died getting
there
because they would have to like walk
across the desert and they would like
they would castrate them
i don't know yeah but um
do you do you know about monsanto
um
he
i don't know i i don't know what country
is so don't don't come for me but
he was from somewhere in the continent
of africa he is like the richest man in
the world even in today's currency he'd
still be the richest man in the world
um
and
he had slaves well that's like
part of how he was making his money
really yeah anyway but it was it was
there were a bunch of things that he was
doing to make his money
he was is he still alive today or this
was like no
this is like a long time ago i don't
know who that is
it's
it's just um
like i just never realized that for a
really long time
seldom participated in the raids that
captured and enslaved africans that
enabled most people in europe and the
americas to remain oblivious to the
traumatic experience that this was with
some africans committing suicide to
avoid capture and wives being whipped as
they tried to cling to their husbands or
children
historian dick i think the difference is
like there's slavery
in the sense of
as a servant
and then
the
slavery that how you're how you
how i'm assuming how you perceived it
that's tied with colonization western
colonization
okay what's the difference okay so say
like
i i'm gonna kidnap you and i'm gonna
have you as like a sex lady for me or
whatever like i'm gonna pimp you out or
whatever
you're you're staying right here versus
actually like transporting you to
another continent or like building
building
the
colony or do you get what i'm saying
i think that's the difference
i don't so you're saying it was
different in america because no no no
how
how they're mentioning slavery and
saying that like slavery has always been
in a sense yes and i'm saying i think
the difference is because
well one that was like hmm
and that sense it it was like one of the
biggest instances of slavery but then
also like they're moving them from like
no the the arabs that was the they were
they transported more slaves than the us
like by far
and on top of that they their death
rates that like they were much
worse like they were like known for
being
like they castrated the guys when they
got there you know effed up that is
but why
why i don't know
like does it matter they're castrating
no i'm not saying why but i'm just
saying in the in the instance of like
saying you read something here about it
like
um because they did that in america as
well like there's a whole bunch of [ __ ]
that they did well yeah yeah but in
america it wasn't like there were some
like it sounds messed up but it's just
true there are some slave owners that
have really good relationships with
their slaves
no they really did like um there's an
autobiography i read by this guy that um
was actually a slave and he he had a
good relationship with like yeah but
that's a one in a few
um
that's one another how do you know were
you alive like
were you alive no but i'm telling you in
the same instance that you're saying
that but that's not the reality for so
many people right i'm not saying it's
like okay but no obviously
their words i'm saying i think in the e
like i would guess it's worse in the
arabs was worse because they were
literally castrating the guys when they
got there
like they were doing that in america as
well no they weren't yes they were that
widespread it wasn't like standard
protocol to castrate them yeah not a
standard protocol but it did happen yes
oh i'm sure
it happened yeah but it's
like i'm telling you the arabs were
known for
like i mean shitty things happened in
both places
but i i don't know what the difference
like you're trapped like
like what's the point
what's my point is no i was responding
to what you said earlier about you said
it's different
no i was just i'm
the only thing i was saying is because
say
it's a different group of people so say
this is like african against european
people so to speak versus like
african and african well there's african
and african and then they were sold to
the europeans huh it was african and
african and then they were sold to the
europeans
i mean on some of them i didn't
no because the average lifespan of a
white guy in africa was a year
so there's like they would die of
malaria
yeah but that was like say like um
when you go to like a hierarchy in that
sense it's like i i'm the king and it's
like you're not gonna take me but out
how they're saying like the weakest
links or whatever but the people that
the game is like less valuable or
whatever but either way they're all a
part of this [ __ ] so yeah well i thought
it
someone told me here that it was
nigerians that were the ones i mean dear
to west coast i don't
i don't know i couldn't tell you
but
like nigeria as you know it today
because nigeria is um different
um
there are different tribes in nigeria
and the different
and any parts of africa now like the
the regions and
the countries as we know it today is not
as it were before so say in nigeria
specifically they have different tribes
like um you can be igbo edu
europa and stuff so
they've just come together but they were
not always like that like that's why
yeah yeah the difference that's just
what someone told me here
like we live in um london
they might not know we live in london
david breon davis pointed out that
europeans had little contact with the
actual process of enslavement and that
as late as 1721 the royal african
company asked its agents to investigate
the modes of enslavement in the interior
europeans typically saw only the end
results enslaved people being offered
for sale on the coast
it was much the same story in the
ottoman empire where those who bought
slaves had no idea what these slaves had
been through before
the unique position of the western world
in the history and especially the
destruction of slavery need not imply
that there was unanimity within the west
on this institution
in addition to whites who defended the
enslavement of africans on racial
grounds or who opposed general
emancipation on social grounds there
were many whites and even blacks who
defended slavery as a matter of
self-interest as slave owners
although most black owners of slaves in
the united states were only nominal
owners of members of their own families
there were thousands of other blacks in
the antebellum south who were commercial
slave owners just like their white
counterparts
an estimated one-third of the free
persons of color in new orleans were
slave owners and thousands of these
slave owners volunteered to fight for
the confederacy during the civil war
black slave owners were even more common
in the caribbean
in short there were many defenders of
slavery in the west even in the 19th
century
and outside the west slavery was too
widely accepted to require defense
isn't that insane
isn't that insane
i won't think it's insane nothing shocks
me like i when i heard that my the first
time my mouth dropped one third of freed
slaves owned slaves
and then fought for the confederacy
my brother what the [ __ ] where's the
worst is like facts coming from this
this is from thomas sowells yeah but
where did he get the back from where he
he spent his whole career researching
this stuff
like this man i promise you you will not
find a guy
that
is
more like well
like this man has spent 50 years just
researching this [ __ ]
i don't think i want to believe that i'm
not saying it's sure or not i mean it's
not for either one of us to say because
we weren't a [ __ ] life
but
yeah just well i think the point is that
it like it was just an institution back
then
not just like it was a terrible
institution
but
like i think that's
the
one out of three
that's crazy
i i don't i don't even see how that's
possible when a lot of um
like if you're asleep you don't have any
money so how are you going to be a slave
owner yourself like um
you can be in charge of your your
what is your plantation like say you can
be the one that is the overseer
like they were overseers yeah
and
they might be like they might mean it in
that sense like overseers working like
above the slaves but still
enslaving like they're still working for
the master well they're freed though
i don't know
do you think he just made that up
it doesn't be i don't think that he had
to have made it up but i think it could
be a version of the truth that he's
wanting to go with
why would he want to do that
i don't know i don't know
okay
it's just um
it's just it seems like when sometimes
when you get like facts you don't like
you don't really
like it's like you just don't believe
them
i just i i'm like it doesn't
how does that make sense if i don't have
any money how am i gonna how am i gonna
like buy slaves well it makes perfect
sense to me because it's what you know
how to do no but listen you would have
to have the financial means to be able
to have slaves because like you're
having to be afraid so you can get a job
and so if like if you grew up on a
plantation and that's what you know how
to do then you would like that's a
business you know how to run
so it's like if i grew up like i worked
at my parents software company
and like i know how to run that business
and then like maybe i'm enslaved i'm
forced to do it right but then i get
free that's the skills i have like that
to me that that makes sense but i don't
think you have this skill um yeah cause
you would you'd be working on no
orientation no that's that i was gonna
say it's like i don't think you have the
skills like to run it but then it could
be the same sense of like say you're
playing on a team and you could be the
captain like
i don't know
okay
no other nation ended slavery in the
same way as the united states did and
few ended it after so short a struggle
as history is measured
how and why did slavery end in most of
the world
there were two major processes
over the centuries as more and more
territories around the world
consolidated into nation-states with
their own armies and navies
raiding those territories to capture and
enslave the people who lived within them
became more hazardous in itself and also
risked military retaliation against the
countries from which the raiders came
thus more and more peoples became off
limits to slave raiders over time
put differently the areas which remain
subject to slave rating over the
centuries were primarily those where the
people lived in smaller or weaker
societies
such societies continue to exist where
it was difficult for geographic or other
reasons to consolidate large areas under
one government
this was true of the balkans the back
waters of asia and much of sub-saharan
africa
by the early modern era sub-saharan
africa with its numerous and severe
geographic handicaps was one of the last
remaining areas from which vast numbers
of people could be enslaved
okay wait is this over it was over so
question so the reason i brought this up
because i when i watched this video i
had a question for you
so when we were talking about like
systemic racism and how it like trickles
down
um assuming assuming that fact is true
right do you think it still trickles
down if they were the slave owners
wait what trickles down so you were
talking about how like
like on one of the shows we did it was
like systemic racism yes similar racism
but what part about and we're saying
it's from slavery right so how does it
work if if one out of three people in
louisiana
were slave owners like
are they then on the beneficiary side or
they still
i i get that but i don't think and
overall i don't think that they would
benefit from it because if the system is
meant to benefit a certain race okay
they will still be class like the same
way you know you can be a free slave in
one place but then
like even freed slaves were um kidnapped
and brought back into slavery right so
they're still not benefiting because
they're they're not they wouldn't be on
the right race okay so to you so it
doesn't matter if they were slave owners
or not
in the sense of how you're saying
yes yes no it wouldn't matter because
okay if the argument is that systemic
racism
systemic
racism
is about a race it's not about
uh it's not a systemic classism yeah
it's racism so if you're still
a certain race i don't care what
whatever you look like or what merits
you have you're still falling under that
race no matter how hard you're gonna say
no like you're still going to be black
you're still going to be white it's
going to be asian indigenous okay so
what about like do you think like willow
smith
do you feel like she's in any way
oppressed
no she's [ __ ] rich okay so there's
certain people that you wouldn't say are
like falling under that
it
they're they're different factors as in
anything there are different factors um
but
she's part of the one percent
okay so you would say like
basically like if you're black and
you're in the one percent you don't like
then you don't
fall under like the systemic racism that
happens no because what job is she even
working under like she doesn't do [ __ ]
like obviously she doesn't know
something but yeah like she doesn't do
[ __ ] in the sense that like she doesn't
have to do anything
but she does stuff off of her own
pursuit so like what would you say like
top like 10
maybe an income and then like the bottom
like 90
all fall under
yeah i think it just depends on what
you're doing okay um
what you're doing
um and
yeah it would be under what you're doing
because
it's whatever system that you're under
so if i'm not within a certain system
how's that gonna affect me i'm not in
here
okay
what is the system
say
uh the government and different like
corporations
okay so like is there a government like
law that's what is it
or a specific corporation
there's
there are certain things have been made
to like
to so that
the different races can benefit and when
i'm saying different races it's like
most mostly like white people even say
when you go
how they're hispanic people like when
you know when you're doing it in
something about race and it's like are
you hispanic yes or not and they even
only brought that then because they
didn't want to be treated like black
people was like oh
like who who didn't want to be treated
hispanic people like say mexicans
especially like
in what
in the us government oh she was saying
when you had like the census
yeah okay so you're saying they added
that to the census to yeah like so
whenever like you see forms that's how
they brought it about because they
didn't want to be they they didn't want
to say that they were black like
obviously they're not black
some some same people are black but so
like today that's a form of racism is
like filling out the census box no i'm
not saying that that's racism i'm saying
even when how how the the things are
there so how is like white black asian
they even have the option of being
hispanic because
like that's how that came about
well i just like
obviously racism is real right and like
that obviously exists but i just don't
know like what
systemically like because it doesn't
seem like a a census box is really going
to hold you back no i'm not that's not
what i said
i'm saying i was i was just letting you
know like that was a lot of things sorry
no that's how it like how hispanic is on
the thing is because
they didn't want to be treated the same
way black people
okay
we're treated correct okay that was the
point okay
so but but my question is like it's like
what laws are like
like systemic because when you say
systemic racism it seems like it would
be
some sort of law or like pursue like
something like that needs to be changed
today
i think when you go and like read
i i can't tell you like okay and i i get
i get that i get that this is gonna be
bad okay that's okay okay but
it's like you have to redefine linings
of the same way you do for anything like
anything how like i think your principle
is like reading what things are actually
saying but reading the fine lines and
saying like oh well who's on the benefit
of this or why is it said like this or
why was this created like this
okay so so sorry i don't understand
just reading the fine lines of whatever
is read
reading defined reading the fine lines
oh the fine
the fine lines of whatever is said yeah
okay so
reading the fine lines so it's like
you're wondering like why stuff was put
in place
and like yeah like actually like read
what is there and
not just
yeah find out fully what is something
meaning
okay because to me like to me it doesn't
matter what stuff means it matters like
what it does
yeah but it would
be it would be
worked on based off of what it says
so like for the census example like if
someone like that was their reasoning
when they first put it in like okay
but like if it doesn't
like if they're just taking data today i
didn't say that system racism i was i
was mentioning okay the fact that that
is why
the hispanic option is even there okay i
just was wondering if there was like an
example
no
i can come back later it's okay like you
don't know what we're watching so i
don't expect you to have everything like
laid out yeah
but i was just you you but i still think
that like you guys can have your own
perception um but again
if you're white you're not going to be
able to experience something like that's
not meant to affect you because if
systemic racism is against whatever race
like if
if there's something in place to benefit
a white person or to
go against a white person i'm not going
to experience that because i'm not white
so i wouldn't be on the the bad side or
the good side of that like i could see
the good but i wouldn't be able to
experience that so i still think some
racism is a thing but i just look like i
just look at everyone as individuals and
so i don't feel like everyone has the
same experience no one said that
everyone has the same experience but
he's like when you're implying systemic
racism it kind of kind of does just
means that there's a system in place
right but then i like right but then
it's like what's the system
it would be under like
say say how the video that we watched it
was um not this video by the way there's
a different we've watched a couple
um but
say how they were referring to the
housing and the different things of like
the banks like
the banks especially
um
when you look at
it as a system versus like
because we could have the same credit
score like the same
the same merit if you want to call it
that
our qualifications we have the same
qualifications and then
we put in
one person as xyz race and the other one
is another race and it's like well why
are why is this person having anything
that we have everything the same or even
i'm on a better foot
um
and
the example i can give right now up top
of my head um there was a black family
they got there they got a they got their
house appraised
and
it was a nice house like they lived a
good area and stuff and
they only got like a
a couple hundred thousand
and
it didn't sit right with them so they
got their house like they took
everything that had to do like their
family pictures and stuff down and just
made it like a generic house
um when their house got appraised and
they weren't there they had their white
friends
be there like as they filled with their
house and they got um
like over half a million more
okay and it's the same house like same
everything they just take away
everything that would indicate that it
was a black family
okay so you feel like that's like very
widespread
yeah different systems like that okay
um because the when we watched that
video yeah i thought it was because
people that lived in that like those
areas
tended to default on loans more and
that's why they were denied
and those areas tended to be black
no i don't think it's like that like i
would have we would have to re-watch the
video again because i can't like blindly
reference something yeah um
but
yeah that's i can't blind something okay
well i think i understand a little bit
better what you're talking about it's
like instances like that yeah maybe we
can do another video
okay
okay um well guys let us know in the
comments what you thought of this video
again i always appreciate talking to
people that are like on the other side
of the aisle i think it's good
let us know what you want to see us talk
about yeah let us know in the comments
what we should react to next
um subscribe to her channel like this
video and we'll talk to you guys next
time but if you don't we have beef oh
yeah